alle zehn jahre das ist jetzt 15 jahre
ja ungefähr traurig neue gartenmöbel und
jetzt muss man business war corona cetin
ich glaube viele leute haben in dieser
besonderen zeit unter quarantäne
investiert in terrassen ausbau
verschönerung des patrons gartenmöbel es
war ja auch bombenwetter und dann habe
ich eingekauft zu knapp 10.000 neueste
studie noch ein gartentisch und ein
sonnenbad
freude bis die sachen kam dann hätte die
freude auf also ich hatte das gefühl und
auch meine begleiter ich war nicht
alleine wir waren zu dritt dass das was
wir gekauft haben und im geschäft
gesehen haben nicht der qualität
entsprach die dann ausgeliefert wurde
und dann habe ich noch von anderen
wollten gehört die sich eine
couchgarnitur gekauft haben nicht da
anderswo ausprobiert haben und
festgestellt haben bei lieferung es ist
nicht die couchgarnitur auf der wir
gesessen und meint verdacht nährt sich
allmählich das hier unter umständen auch
gerade unter corona aspekten mein
zuhause wichtiger wird der garten
wichtiger wird wo das um dich herum
einfach wichtiger wird dass da auch eine
nummer geschoben wird die den saft
lästigen mal kaufen wir sehen dem laden
schöne sachen und kriegen eine
verminderte qualität nach hause da kann
ich verstehen da ist jeder aufgeregt
natürlich nicht nur maler räte
schreinemakers gut dass sie sich an uns
gewandt hat wir haben natürlich auch in
diesem fall recherchiert ich hatte
versprochen frau schreinemakers wir
schauen mal was wir machen können
nur ich sags ganz von vorne rein wir
sind leider auch gescheitert also wir
haben mit dieser firma rostock kontakt
aufgenommen
es gibt überhaupt keine hotline auf der
website wir haben dann in der filiale
angerufen wo frau schreinemakers
eingekauft hat dort hieß es wählen sie
diese nummer die war nur besetzt am ende
sind wir in den usa gelandet und hätten
uns da erkundigen müssen als
pressevertreter
ich finde das ist unglaublich wir
bleiben natürlich dran am champions das
war auch genau das worüber sich auch vor
schreinemakers geärgert hatte ja total
und man musste in diesem fall hatten wir
wieder deutlich gemerkt dass verkaufen
geht viel schneller als das reklamieren
und das geltendmachen von berechtigten
mängel rügen sowie was er hier hatten
denn die qualität stimmte nicht und es
waren eben mängel aufgetaucht und sie
hat ja auch noch berichtet dass
sozusagen die ware regelrecht porös war
uns ja quasi bei regen sich schon fast
aufgelöst hat und das ist für
gartenmöbel natürlich nicht in ordnung
und da muss man wirklich dranbleiben und
das ist ärgerlich ist dass sie die
unternehmen versuchen die verbraucher
die kunden eben sozusagen einer langen
hand zu halten und eben nicht zu
reagieren und manche werden daneben
mürbe machen dich weiter und das sollte
man nicht tun sondern eben massiv
dranbleiben und ein wichtiger tipp
tatsächlich jeder kennt das da kommen
möbel aufbaue
die bauern zack zack zack was aus sagen
oh wir sind schon verspätet wir müssen
schnell nach hause
sollte ich dann lieber die ware prüfen
denn auch tatsächlich margarethe
schreinemakers hat offenbar andere möbel
bekommen als sie bestellt hat wichtig
ist vor allem dass man nichts
unterschreibt also erstmal sollte man
beim kaufvertrag und wenn man die ware
besichtigt fotos machen von der
besichtigten ware damit man hinterher
auch das bekommt was man bestellt hat
dann sollte man wenn es geht zeugen
mitnehmen
und was ganz wichtig ist bei der
vertrags eingehung dass man sich nicht
so auf ja so flammen welche zusagen
einlässt irma beispielsweise fragt ist
das denn für draußen geeignet zum
beispiel und der verkäufer sagt
selbstverständlich dann sollte man das
einen vertrag schreiben denn man merkt
dann schon sehr genau ob das ob diese
zusage die man abverlangt hat ob die
jetzt tatsächlich gehalten werden kann
oder nicht denn wenn jetzt wirklich
beispielsweise die möbel geeignet sind
das ganze jahr draußen stehen zu lassen
dann kann man das auch in den vertrag
schreiben und wenn der verkäufer da
schon zurückschreckt dann sollte man
eher die finger davon lassen
und wenn man die ware dann bekommt bitte
ebenfalls wieder fotos machen und vor
allen dingen nichts unterschreiben wo
quasi drinsteht ware ordnungsgemäß
erhalten
man sollte dann gar keine unterschrift
leisten oder wenn man schon
unterschreibt immer drunter schreiben
unter vorbehalt auch ganz wichtig
tatsächlich also das kann auch jedem
passieren was margarethe schreinemakers
da passiert ist